[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby just my American
that's what they are American
I talked to Josh about that jacket I
want to talk about his Adventure when he
was somewhere in the middle of
Albuquerque or somewhere and you went
into that gas station and it had what it
had okay I'll tell you what I bought I'd
like to know wait fill us in apparently
you and I talked to fill the rest of us
I went that jacket and then he I did a
little oh he said he got it well watch
this I did a little Josh that jacket
yeah I bought at a gas station in New
Mexico what tell me more I go on the gas
station the sign when I was driving by
and by the way gas station purchases in
the South and in the West can be amazing
because some of them have like but this
one said
uh Mexican food donuts and stuff I'm in
stomach stuff so I bought this jacket I
bought a bow and arrow I bought
fireworks now that's nice leather oh
that's human yes
yeah that is a Native American man's
skin but that's fine because when you
say stuff it's true that you could find
like you could find like a dehydrated
heart a human heart tattoo human skull
yeah like a necklace of yours Voodoo
[ __ ] stuff is all you never know but
also a poncho
fireworks stuff you need yeah Ceramics
yep the bone area the boat yeah [ __ ]
for sure Miller life you're not the same
because I love the best the best I've
ever had I'm just gonna say the best
shirt Dave that they don't have like the
[ __ ] everybody dude they have Real
Jerk It's Made and the flavors are well
it's made from the farm Yonder in the
backyard it's made from the Food they'll
have like blueberry the one of those
like blueberry or habit habanero [ __ ]
mango bear meat they'll have bear meat
they'll have armadillo they'll have all
kinds of different Meats all you know
armadillo right now I'm so alive which
is delicious armadillo are you still
just meat uh now I prefer the last two
weeks I have been
and my headache is popping right now
that's why I have whiskey whiskey and
whiskey and meat is what they ate as
they were settling in the west now let
me ask you this whoever made this jacket
that's all they did so come on hold on
how much was the jacket come on man how
much you think let's take a couple
guesses okay I'm gonna say I'm gonna
tell you right now wait this is New
Mexico New Mexico did they serve green
chili at this place no no rest well on
the side actually there was a restaurant
I didn't go over there that jacket was
89.99
it was 49.99 if you would go Price is
Right it's 75 that would be wow but you
were actually closer yes I mean this is
a 75 jacket that's a steal dude now the
bow and arrow yes could you use it to
kill small game
if I had a bow and arrow skill I believe
so oh wait you got bow and arrow and the
jacket yeah did it come with the jacket
no but I wish it had Grand great
incentive yeah they should they should
be like you know what you can have this
bone arrow oh I also bought some maracas
well you need those those are fun can I
get a lava lamp I they were there but I
didn't buy it okay can I tell you what I
used the maracas for so I I like to I
don't I'm not a good golfer but I like
to golf with my brothers and my dad
because it's just bonding [ __ ] but we
only golf here in LA or in the desert in
Vegas
and there's always a danger rattlesnake
sign so I pack a Maraca in my golf bag
because I'm terrible golf but I like
making people scared so I always mention
it once or twice I'll be like hey guys
remember this rattle things out here
this rattlesnakes and the first time
somebody goes in the wood and pokes
around for their ball I just
sh loud [ __ ] dude when you think you
touch a rattlesnake you know like in the
cartoons where your feet yes yeah
yeah those rattlesnakes are loud well
now in Texas because people kill them
all the time they've evolved to not
rattle what do you mean man they stop
rattling because they're getting killed
but they're giving themselves away so
one smart route that Elon Musk of
rattlesnakes went I'm just gonna stop
shaking my tail yeah and then I went
that's a great idea dude every time we
do it we get killed so he called the
council among the other snakes gather
around gather around everyone I have an
idea no more rides no more rattling
equals Death and then someone's like
hold on that's what he ran for office
the snake raises him just a quick
question it's kind of our thing yeah
because not anymore dumbass the snake
rattled his tail so you everybody look
at him he goes we don't do that anymore
he goes well how was I supposed to raise
my hand use your tongue
I I wish they would continue to rattle
that's one man's opinion but why'd you
buy a [ __ ] we're getting herpetology
in a second why did you why did you
purchase a goddamn bow and arrow
why not I was there at the gas station
dude yeah Slurpee jerky Bono and arrow
human skull fireworks like hot dogs I'll
tell you what my shirt was honest my
plan was I had mushrooms with me
my plan was and I bought some fireworks
my plan was to somehow try to light the
arrow and set up fireworks and shoot
them when I was tripping are you 13.
yeah basically yeah
zero bow and arrow skills I've never
shot one before it's not you can't just
pick it up and do it can I just say
something yeah I got a lot of friends we
all have friends who are super into
archery one of them's name is Joe Rogan
and there are a couple of guys I think
that um I don't care about archery now
I'm an adult and I know it's a skill set
I could give less of a [ __ ] about
archery I care more about what the
weather's like in I don't know Beijing
right now yeah like I could give a [ __ ]
oh do you are you good at shooting did
you kill did you kill that elk but wait
with a bow and arrow didn't you call it
in with a horn
which basically is like I'm a dude this
pussy's
who the [ __ ] said that yeah you
catfished yeah who said that somebody
said something and then you go oh he's
10 yards away or or you pose with it
yeah you like killed it or they spray
the trees with like so it smells like
like a male so you get the females in
you just Honey dick them the Honey dick
and they shoot them in the face they
walk towards you let me ask you like
it's it's called Native Americans what
is what is what do you feel is worse
that or sitting up in a stand just
waiting for the animal to walk past also
suspect because that's not hunting
that's waiting yeah and I would say the
kind of hunting I did with ranela where
you actually walk and you you stalk the
deer that shit's really hard so for I I
believe this is the case I know that
when sniper training school a lot of
times they I'm correct me if I'm wrong
but I've heard this from Fairly reliable
source no but but I know people who
listeners are in the military but this
the stains when you when you [ __ ] uh
stalk an elk with a rifle okay when you
actually go to stalking out they can
smell you a mile away they can see you a
mile away so they are so smart they see
you and they're like I'm getting the
[ __ ] away from you so the way you have
to stalk an elk is is a very similar
skill set as how you stalk a human enemy
you can't be seen and you got to take a
long [ __ ] shot yeah we know this do
you know that's difficult who's an
expert bow hunter it is Foxworthy
Jeffrey Jeff Foxworthy is Jeffrey
Foxworthy dude is like world class is he
yeah well I I got to know John Dudley
who's the best in the world and that
shooting John yeah John 6 6 2 30. it
just looks like a [ __ ] crazy athlete
which it was and uh he's the best in the
world and there he is you know and so
when you when you're on that level
that's a whole different you don't have
to wear a hat like that yes that's a
whole different level of this all of
them were the hat like I see a hat like
that I'm like that's like cauliflowers
for Fighters and definitely not like
that yeah definitely wearing Oakleys if
you see a hat like that run in a ziggy
yeah look at him that [ __ ] is a Zen
practice he's a [ __ ] he's a Savage
what's up kids let's take a little break
from chatting your ear off about bows
and arrows with Josh Wolf and Brian
count and myself they're both taking
shits right now so you got your boy here
doing the reads but I will be in San
Jose this Thursday Friday Saturday San
Jose Improv is this freaking week we
just announced all new tour it's a oh he
thick Tor and we have new dates new
cities just got added on there we'll be
announcing a big UK tour for next year
we've got a lot of fun stuff coming up
so go to thick boy or uh fatkz.com right
now get your tickets but this week at
San Jose next week Salt Lake City Utah
that's October 20th through the 22nd at
Wise Guys Calgary October 27th at the
rooftop downtown Calgary Thursday show
Almost sold out so we add a show on
Friday out there November heavy Texas we
have San Antonio November 3rd through
the 5th at LOL Houston November 10th
through the 12th a bunch of dates in
between then but the next big one is
December 15th through the 17th
Washington DC with my favorite clubs DC
Improv come get you some December 15th
to the 17th we'll announce a bunch more
dates for Ohi thick tour get you some
also that sweet sweet nectar the
award-winning nectar from your thick
friend here is just restocked if you go
to thickboy.com and get you some right
now it gets delivered to your door get
you that award-winning thick nectar
tiger thick it's available right now
finally back in stock batch two coming
in hot you'll see the awards on the
bottles get you some right now delivered
to your door this episode of the fighter
and the kid is brought to you by better
help that's right life can be tough man
and you need a little help out there you
know who can help you you know you don't
have to figure out your own Solutions
nope you need some help and that's where
a professional therapist can help you
become a better Problem Solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or small these therapists
are going to help you it's all done
online your boy is in therapy but
friends in therapy whether you got tons
of stress you got you need help with
anxiety depression we got you covered
man all right if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try do it the easy way
do it with better help it's a great
option it's convenient it's accessible
it's definitely affordable and it's
entirely online do it from the comfort
of your home you match with therapist
after filling out a brief survey and you
switch your therapist at any time if
you're not feeling it or you think you
could find a better one all good they
will switch it for you no questions
asked so when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com fighter today get
10 off your first month that's better
help.com fighter fellas you know when
you're just wearing something
uncomfortable man you're like God this
is not comfortable this is It's too
tight it's wrinkly I've been wearing all
day I'm supposed to go to happy I'm
supposed to go to the movies let's go to
place let's go a comedy show so if you
go to Bishop's new tour oh he thick and
I'm I'm coming straight from work in
this shirt it's all wrinkled I look
terrible well you need some rone in your
life man you need some Roan because they
make dope shirts dope pants they got it
all to help you look great it and they
have a shirt that they sent to me I rock
it my dad actually stole it from me this
Rhone uh shirts the commuter shirt it's
a button up it's breathable it's
flexible and it's fantastic it's also
four-way stretch so you have to worry
about it and also it's wrinkle free like
I told you you don't want to sit at work
driving your car you get out your
shirt's all wrinkly you're going to
dinner you're going on a date you're
going to comedy show you look ridiculous
now if you got wrong daddy if you got
Rowan you look fantastic so if you want
to jump on board look dope at work look
dope at the theater date night at the
comedy show get the commuter shirt from
Roan and guess what you head to roan.com
fighter use promo code fighter you save
20 off your entire order that's 20 off
your entire order when you head to
rhone.com fighter use the code fighter
it's time to find your corner office
Comfort have you seen the Japanese
masters of archery have you read Zen In
The Art of archery no small book
important book yeah very good are you
ready no no it's about archery yeah but
in Japan it's about life but about
archer in Japan though overall right but
it's a metaphor Cat in the Hat right no
is that in there is how you breathe when
you hold all that I'm out yeah are these
pictures in the book no but if you watch
go go to YouTube I'll tell you who I
want shoes I mean the guy in the middle
which one which one do you think yeah
you want that dude yeah well they would
practice they would practice riding on a
horse and splitting an arrow or shooting
a bird in midair all these crazy you
know why
nothing else to do right well you know
why yeah because back then yeah nothing
to do yeah hold on right yes but sir
nothing sir I would say go to the master
Archer from the National Geographic I
don't know like there's the head above
the head shot too though
but sir I would say this it maybe you
learn about life if you master one thing
you master everything isn't that the
idea yeah but you were just [ __ ] on
our Channel didn't you just tell me how
dumb are you they said you don't give us
two seconds
two seconds ago
I just told us I care more about it
then pull up Zen In The Art of archery
I've actually researched it for 10 years
I do not care about archery but I do
like this craftsmanship this master
Japanese Master this this this Sensei
who makes his own bows so you do care
about our [ __ ] how long is this video
chin yeah yeah
it's it's 11 minutes too long my
attention watch this but it's above the
head he's wearing glasses
oh then he lowers it yeah that's cool
dude but but why is but what's that look
at that release oh no I need to hear
that noise
wearing a hat like I want you to take
his hat in
hold on is that a hat or a headband wait
oh [ __ ] yeah there was no need for that
wow the target hitting us but he waited
till I didn't do it
that's a war cry and that's the last
thing you hear is you die you go like
this watch no you're already out you go
two you go huh
that warning seems kind of late yeah I'm
already like yeah I'm already you've
already hit me with the arrow and then
you're like hey well I'm gonna tell you
this when you get when you get killed
with an arrow it goes through your body
it doesn't stay in your body I'll really
get a shot goes right to your body Bubba
yeah and it goes right through your
heart and you're gonna do this you're
going to be talking and you're gonna go
watch you're gonna be like oh dude I got
it right okay do it ready I do so yeah
an arrow doesn't go through your body
I've seen too many moves
yeah no no no it goes through your body
I'll go straight if it's the right if
it's there so you want to hit him up
here so it doesn't go all the way
through right wow you want that in the
heart yeah you do that have you know
that now a little fact for you know it's
a dragon closing out I did not know you
yeah shooting bows and arrows yeah you
sure you grew up shooting Arrows with a
ball yes right bows and arrows now when
did you do that so since probably
[ __ ] second grade through eighth
grade okay so I had my own bone area
side of the range SJ yeah can I see your
pullback sure what does that mean
no didn't you see the pictures yeah
that's how they were doing it yeah I
pulled my back and I kissed I kiss it
here it creases right here
and you say that's exactly what I do
and by the way when I breathe you know
they have triggers on them now too we
just go thank you so so here's back it
locks and Trigger if I'm shooting you if
I'm shooting you at a distance with a
scope or a bow and arrow watch this this
is my breathing
breathe in watches
and when I'm out of breath that's that
pause now you left the bone air I'd
assume it was your bone arrow was it uh
just it was wood yeah man it wasn't like
yeah you know what I'm saying calm down
yeah yeah it's called a gas station they
took us down this boring Road dude I
mean my man's just gas station you got a
cup of chili and a leather jacket and we
decided to get a [ __ ] pain
and you're like
Japanese
no I wanted the store is not Albuquerque
but I wanted him to show the Japanese
guy splitting the arrow he's splits an
arrow but you told us before that
[ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ] so we
already know dude
I want to watch about [ __ ] that none of
us care about you wasted all of our
lives [ __ ] that was a long archery
tangent the longest archery tangent ever
that's our time guys thank you for
tuning in I looked over in that video
and chilling like this
yeah oh my God that was yeah wait what
were you doing in New Mexico oh dude
we're on tour yeah a little theater tour
down there
I do not carry a weapon I don't care
blade I do not carry a blade were you in
Albuquerque I was in Albuquerque let me
tell you something
Albuquerque Albuquerque well telling the
story yeah when you had to kick somebody
out oh yeah yeah in Albuquerque in
Roswell they'd be farting out there man
that was not the green chili if you use
it they fart hard I've been there a
bunch of times okay but yeah so wait
there's more to Albuquerque than that
you're right yeah I did see I did see
bumper sticker they said Albuquerque
you'd be farting yeah
that's actually thick boy yeah
and the guy at the club straight up told
me hey but you usually don't kick people
out unless we call because everyone's
packing
yeah yeah it's just such a good guy was
the guy just out of control the guy was
look man my shows are super Good
Vibes across the board it's a fun time
yeah man I'm I'm another jacket on yeah
dude we're just having a good time bring
your stuff on stage I yeah and I'm not
I'm just not tolerant I've been doing
this a long time yeah I don't have any
tolerance for it and if you're going to
disrupt the show I'm gonna kick you the
[ __ ] out you know it's not weird but all
the like all the comics I've been doing
for a long time like obviously I'll
entertain some of it and like roast them
then if it goes on it's okay we gotta
get scattered like Joe Coy Dalia dude
when there's hecklers I've seen Joe coyo
in a big theater hold on stop that turn
the lights on this guy out and then
we'll wait there until you lose lights
turn back on then he goes if you Julia
shut the [ __ ] get out like holy [ __ ]
just the older Brogan they don't take
[ __ ] for me it says if you're part of
the show
I'm cool with that and then if I feel
like it's gone on too long I'll tell you
hey this is enough We're not gonna do
any more if you are not part of the show
if you're talking to people at the table
if you're making the show not good for
the people around you Zero Tolerance
yeah I'm not your teacher I'm not your
[ __ ] father this is my job if you're
[ __ ] up for everybody else at parties
are not allowed to sit in anywhere near
the front room that's crazy because they
just are not interested in comedy you
know what Marin does you know what
Marion's done this at a show he'll get
there and I'll get on stage and look in
the back and if he sees it's like a
bachelor bachelorette party up get him
out of here before you even starts out
because I'll refund your money myself
get out they're not there for a show wow
he knows he like he's been there like
nope absolutely not get out whoa Savage
I will tell you for me right now without
a doubt and we've been doing this a long
time dude I I've never had more fun on
stage I've never enjoyed my job more
than I am right now I've never been more
invigorated to be on stage do you know
why dude
I'm a different person than when I left
La I really feel like a different human
and I stopped I think you're better than
us now I am yeah that is jacket Brendan
look at this you got away from the the
from The Vortex of LA and just like the
the team I remember talking to you about
this I want to hear about it dude here's
the biggest thing what I stopped doing
I always did this with my stand-up like
I'm I feel pretty Fearless on stage I'll
try [ __ ] and I because I've never
considered something not working on
stage of failure I've always looked at
comedy as a puzzle right and so if a
piece doesn't work that if you put
together a thousand piece puzzle you're
gonna try some pieces that don't work
you don't think of that as failure you
think I just need to find another piece
and I've always thought of Comedy that
way which is why I've always been super
free to do whatever
but I've started to look at my life that
way I no longer think of things as
failure I just need to try a different
piece
that small switch I [ __ ] love that
has changed my entire life dude because
I don't judge myself anymore
you get out of LA to realize that I
really did because I'm not listening to
him when I was here and I'm gonna be
honest with you I would compare myself
to you to you why is there a podcast why
aren't I on this show how come I'm not
doing this stand up and I'm not that
dude I'm not genuinely happy for
people's you're one of the best people I
have ever I mean all [ __ ] aside
you're one of the best [ __ ]
I've ever met I appreciate you think
what he did for for listen man you were
going through your [ __ ] when when Brian
can be on the show
name a single comment they would not
come on the show absolutely not C's too
hot can't do it we love you man we love
Brian but just step and do it and then I
call Josh and you're like I'm there man
I went are you [ __ ] me dude look I'm
there like but that's why I told you
like you're like hey can I come and show
I'm like but you bro just the way you
check in on people and and the way
you're chatting with me so happy for
people is such a rare thing and there's
a purity to you I think it might come
from the fact that you had to raise
three kids on your own I remember I knew
you back then Bubba yeah I met you back
then I knew you when your children were
one children children that's how long
I've known you and uh I don't know man
I've I've watched you I think what
you're talking about is uh peace of mind
and and I I really appreciate that
because as I'm getting older too I
realize I talk to myself in a really
shitty way we're always comparing you
and I still know he and I have the
biggest problem with that like he and I
always like just always moving forward
never stopping to look around what's
going on you know and that's so
exhausting after a while I'm exhausted
it's exhausting dude and why I rip my
jeans why compare it so to your point
man it's a great thing can I tell you
your little jacket smells like the
Liberty yeah come get in there you know
my brother said to me you smell it no I
like it ready for this this is for you
guys too my brother I remember
complaining once and he goes Josh
I want you to think about in the history
of people who've done your job
I know you're comparing yourself to
people who are more successful there's
always people more successful in their
history of people who have done your job
you're in the one percent dude what are
you complaining about you're in the one
percent of people who have ever
attempted this job you're in the one
percent I wish my agent would talk to me
like that and I was like I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like why of course there's always
Chappelle or Rogan or somebody who's but
that doesn't mean I have nothing to do
with you zero Zed I have zero Lively
Comics that are super negative it's like
if you someone's just getting there like
hey this person's success has nothing to
do with you the reason you're so salty
is because of you yeah that's why you're
like I had two billionaires who have all
the money you know uh break that down
for me they they're pretty rational
people and they said hold it they said
I've made a lot of money you know so but
let's take a look at what you've built
let's take a look at the odds when you
go into it and let's let's say how many
people have actually done what you've
done
and he went through it and boy I felt
good about myself for a second dude I
was like because I never feel good about
myself because I hate like I can't watch
it and also be you wouldn't be where
you're at if you were always that guy
too but sometimes you step outside the
box like yeah I'm crushed right it's
like right but but I don't even look
even remotely at it but I think it is
true that sometimes it's good to just be
like I'm not gonna compare myself with
Rogan or anybody else I'm moving at my
own [ __ ] Pace man and and I I'm I'm
doing the best I can brother there's
nothing wrong with being proud of
yourself either yo dude I agree let me
tell you something you have hit when I
think about you've been at the Pinnacle
of two completely separate professions
dude that is not an easy easy thing to
do tell the internet do you know what
I'm saying but but think about this dude
you were a perf in the UFC that's the
one percent yeah what you're doing in
podcasting oh easily in the one percent
so like and to do it in two separate
professions you never look at the cars
you drive in your family you never step
back and you're like I've done a good
[ __ ] job not once but but that's what
that's a bad thing you have it's not
right I have fashion Nova jeans on
they're torn now listen I will tell you
and I tell you
I'm not doing that one that is a problem
and I'm on a Southwest flight to San
Jose tomorrow yeah no I don't know I'm
on my way to Bridgeport tomorrow I'm
going to Portland I get to fly across
the country you do good looking Portland
dude I get to wake up at 6 a.m I fly
oh yeah I feel like I'll land at 2 30.
then I fight and then I I go from JFK to
Bridgeport go straight there yeah when
you go you go straight there it's how
come oh because well it could be worse
but you remember just a second ago
you're like I'm so grateful and then I
am grateful I am [ __ ] grateful it
doesn't sound like it though right I
don't know particular did it yeah
you know what I'm not grateful when I
get to [ __ ] Burbank gearboard
tomorrow in your boarding group see
outside
dude yo I ended and then when somebody
was what are you doing here what do you
mean I'm on a flight like Southwest like
yeah it's Burbank it's easier to get I
know yeah what boarding group are you a
what are you D God damn by the way when
you get on C I want to tell you big boy
when you get on C everyone is like get I
hope this big [ __ ] doesn't sit
next to me what's weird even if you're
born in group a and you're like all the
way against the window and then the big
dude comes on and I want to go you know
why are the big dudes always getting on
last but it's a but but even to sit next
to him like what are you doing
[Laughter]
hey you want to meet the Shoppers you
want to move back yeah by the way if
you're it's the dripping over into my
seat
you know when the big dude's sitting
next to you in like in like it's like
dripping under every it's oozing onto
your side that's when it depends
sometimes it's really uncomfortable
sometimes it's warm kind of comfort
this is like a big bean bag dude
healthy May hugged me once I was like
this is kind of warm and comfy but also
wet yeah
but also wet
oh my God the big guy
oh my I can feel his undercarriage just
[ __ ] the fumes like Vegas
I don't want to patch him anybody but I
said a bean bag of a woman and there's
no other word for it she's so heavy and
she was so cuddly because she was so
over on my side but I just was like yeah
sometimes I'm gonna use you as my pill
pill you're my pillow pill yes and with
feet you're a pillow with feet and all
good and God bless her but what was I
have to say that she had she had brought
no she brought all the snacks and she
was resting she's fantastic she was
resting them on her stomach does she
offer you anything oh my God you know a
sea otter eats a clams yeah like they
crack them on their tummy I'm not trying
to be a dick she's reclining I'm telling
you she was eating them just eating
crackers now and I bless her but I'm
also like I'm also going I'm also like
okay this is a little much now and also
you're being there she is yes
and I
I finally looked over I was like looking
at her I was like I wanted to be like
you're gonna you're gonna dive diving
see Brian would you like health tips you
think I give a [ __ ] yeah I'm on boarding
groups she didn't I have snacks on my
tits listen if you're eating food off of
your stomach in public you're past
giving [ __ ] about anything did not get
she was she was I can't believe she
didn't offer you anything she didn't
offer me a [ __ ] thing nor does she
sending me but the what's interesting
about her was that she was she was very
very heavy and eating stuff but she also
had taken the time to put fake eyelashes
on that's nice and taking the time to
put some makeup on and have some tattoos
so I'm like and have different piercings
so I'm like there's a there's a level of
vanity there and then there's a level of
I don't give a [ __ ] so the vanity
stopped right below her chin right above
her like that she's like I can have 17
neck rolls and it doesn't matter there's
somebody God bless him yeah it was
amazing but it's so comfy though it's
it's but to see that I feel like that's
rare most time it's so uncomfortable so
it's showing and you gotta fight for
that yeah
in his thigh the armrest is right like
this yes just [ __ ] you know but how
do you sit in a regular seat being as
tall as you are not even reflecting
usually I don't usually I'm In First
Class yeah yeah yeah be cool everyone
would be cool yeah I mean that's what
I'm saying that Southwest I don't know
how you listen my brother's like hey
it's this much if we went fly to LAX
first class or it's a 50-minute flight
on Southwest yeah it's worth it first
class is so expensive I can't do it east
coast of this oh around here especially
now dude oh my God I'm not paying 2300 I
don't [ __ ] off I I will suffer there are
a lot of people I know who have crazy
money and like my one buddy he looked at
the wine list where this he's got a
billion dollars he looked the wine
listen he goes he knew two minutes I do
he goes he goes I like ten he goes I
right you name six right so that's kind
of weird right it's you you're in with
60 of the billionaire you're gonna keep
going yeah what's funny about what you
just said is that when I said
billionaire do you know you know it's
not you know he he he has 100 I know he
has about 200 million in the bank that's
a lot but it's not a plan it's 800
million less though than what it's 800
million right it still feels still just
all the money still feels like a lot
which is all the money though it still
feels like a lot of money but it's not
it's not it's not a billion but it still
feels like now the billionaires like my
boy my boy who owns a restaurant in St
bards that restaurant must do really
well well he said that you'll get
billionaires in there that will spend
70 000 for 16 people on a check seventy
thousand dollars but that's like just
buying you guys win right now that's a
guy who's got that kind of money I'm
gonna spend 70 grand and not bat an eye
oh billion what do you give a [ __ ] yeah
people like that will look at sometimes
wine and they go you're charging a
thousand dollars more than this wine
retails for and I'm not gonna [ __ ] do
it because I pay for Value yeah you get
a lot of that too sometimes they're like
no you're trying to [ __ ] with me you're
trying to [ __ ] me even though a thousand
dollars means nothing you're trying to
[ __ ] me in okay yeah all right dude what
do you want to do you're [ __ ] you're
off you know Melrose well I wouldn't be
like you came here I'd be like this I'd
be like you're [ __ ] me it's fine yeah
I would say nothing dude are you kidding
I would actually almost feel good that
you're [ __ ] me and it doesn't bother
me at all so I went I got married this
weekend I know congratulations
I go to I go to French did you guys have
said I tell the story already on the
podcast when I go to French Laundry
Thomas Keller it's like so French
Laundry is in the menu no but it's a
tasting manager it's so expensive it's
so expensive so I go
um and uh I literally say to my uh I say
I look at the wine list I'm already
paying
so much money it's the most expensive
restaurant but it's the best restaurant
so but is it just you and your wife me
and my wife and the couple that married
us okay Mark and Kendra covered on your
wedding night
it's Baba it's it's so expensive but I'm
gonna tell you I split the bill but I'm
gonna tell you what happened hold on
hold on hold on can you give me an
example when you say it's so expensive
like so so it's 500 a plate just for the
food okay between 300 and 500 Newsome
and Pelosi they're like every night yeah
and during the pandemic like no man no
no now it's the best food it's now
Thomas Keller who's a genius yeah who
came out to the table one of my
highlights because I love food so much
he's got a farm across the street it's
not it's it's that no I mean as in okay
go get me some eggs
to go walk across the street can you
give me some fresh kale go pick it
across the street that they got
everything right there that guy genius
amazing man okay okay
I know I won't I won't okay keep going
shaving the white truffles the whole
[ __ ] thing oh you went truffle daddy
wedding night Baba he pulled out an
apple-sized [ __ ] an apple-sized uh
trophy because you guys are getting
married I want to do something special
no I'm a little Truffle Pig though you
are white truffles Papa white truffles
in season in season two I don't
discriminate in season two months a year
you get them in Croatia maybe Spain and
France certain areas and you use pigs or
dogs truffles they're six feet under the
ground troubles are six feet under the
ground and by the way you have armed
guards protecting your acreage of white
truffles or diamonds down through
generations Diamond trucks yeah and
you're gonna get an armed confidence
because the mafia comes in and tries to
take your truffle okay uh can I ask a
question as not a truffle kind of blood
truffles yeah isn't it just a mushroom
he's never had black stuff
bring up white troubles chin
chin bring up one truffles
this whole speech I was doing better
than his car and go [ __ ] yeah I've never
had like truffles
get into this is this gonna be more
interesting than the archery
conversation yes absolutely not okay yes
because they're truffles
well the best part but they're so good
now you can't eat that food without good
wine but it's just like a mushroom yeah
it's it's four thousand four thousand
pounds yeah yeah now here's the thing
yeah them troubles hate to go back to
make you fart
okay
I'm black truffle will rile your boy's
[ __ ] up on the black drums now just
the black black the white now the white
the white truffles why are they so
expensive uh so rare
uh because you can't find them because
they live six feet under the ground
because you need dogs to get them
because they're grown in parts of the
world yeah they're they're the craziest
delicacy of all time now you got to get
wine and I'm looking at the wine and the
wine is so expensive that I'm like I
can't spend this for food and then when
I I'm not a billion I don't have this
kind of money right so I call the the
sommelier over the expert and you know
what I said to him I just went like this
I go they're not used to hearing this I
go bro listen me I'm not Newsome I said
I said all these wine all all this wine
all these prices they take they're
taking all the energy out of my body
yeah I don't have any energy and I'm
getting married I have no energy and and
and I'm getting married and that's and I
went like that I was raised my head and
you don't even ruining my wedding no he
did he goes like this he goes kind of
wine you're like I go I like over one he
goes okay uh with some age on it he goes
I got you I got you he goes close that
up don't look at that I got you and
that's all he did and he just disappears
so now now they're bringing out crazy
ones that are pairing with it and
they're showing me the bottle I'm like
well that I know how much that cost
matches with the truffles oh and oh and
and Keller comes out and goes let me try
this he comes out in a chat it's a chest
it's a treasure chest with six people
getting married let me help you out
pulls it open pulls out the [ __ ]
truffle goes it's an apple size one I've
never seen one that big I went I went my
girl my girl goes she goes you have to
calm down you're actually I have to calm
down does it taste like a mushroom
tonight
don't tempt me it it's white truffle
season yeah but you gotta shave the
trouble wait but what did you put that
sounds Dirty by the way you're not just
gonna risotto risotto you can put it on
scallops you can put on anything
I gotta take if you have been until
right now they have they have a scallop
dish with a cheese fondue get the [ __ ]
out of here so now hold on at your
wedding truffle and wine my wedding
you're pudding in Tequila but so now
Bubba we're talking I'm out of that I'm
literally I'm already an [ __ ] and I'm
waiting for my business manager to call
me and be like hey [ __ ] face you're not
a land baron and you're spending too
much money because I spend I don't have
any money yeah I don't so uh he goes I
use that money I don't have money
anymore and I don't have the money to go
to [ __ ] French Laundry I'm just being
honest so uh I'm like calculating how
much this is gonna spit I can't
understand why they're bringing this guy
I'm like this guy likes me this guy
[ __ ] likes me he digs me
so now that the bill is going to come
and I'm ready I mean you're paying for
all four oh yeah now I'm expecting a
bill for I don't know what are you
spending three grand 3 500 I don't know
that'll hurt your feelings and I opened
the bill up and there I see a card Seven
Grand I see a card all it says is
congratulations
we love you
love Joey and Karine
and I go who's joined Curry yeah that's
my next question I go uh
my friend Joe heard me I mentioned I was
going to French Laundry in passing the
guy in New York
he lives in London a week
a week before this [ __ ] called
French Laundry and goes get them
whatever they want and make sure you
wind them up hey waiter tell us that
before we yeah they were all laughing
they were the waiter came out and he
goes yeah when you told me that the wine
was taken away because we had everything
planned out I go you [ __ ] knew
they go yeah of course we knew dude put
the bottle down
dude I bring that stupid Pig over here
that's why and Thomas Keller gave us a
tour of the kitchen like for me food
like that kind of food to me is like if
I had the money I'd eat there every day
it's like it's art it's [ __ ] art yeah
what was your main course there though
um well Bubba you take small you have
small dishes that'll knock up it'll be
so hungry it's an explosion
by the time they come on they go you
want more food we're like oh you know
it's like it's it's
so much food but it is a tasting menu
you don't order you just go I want the
tasting menu do you want the new one you
want the traditional tasting menu
traditional yeah do you want just
vegetables do you want just vegetables
no you think no and then you try it oh
no no no no no no no answers no no you
want you ate just vegetables you want
white Quail Bubba you want you want a
certain kind of lamb well I know you
want yeah you want Yellow Tail that's
made just you want yes I ate all what
did you have all of that all that I had
I didn't know there was something called
a white Quail but there is but it's the
way it's prepared and where it's put in
a dish I don't know caviar and scallops
with a cheese thing you're like what the
most liquid is black Quail also known as
a pigeon yeah yeah yeah I I I don't know
that I've had right Quail I had wood
pigeon in France
I don't know but it's a it's a pigeon
that lives in the wild it's [ __ ] hell
with you Asians are the Rats of this you
ate his head they give you the head I
ate the head
and they cover your face they cover you
with a napkin they block the other
diners with a napkin and then you eat
the head take the head and you go home
is doing this they're eating a [ __ ]
decision head yes the waiter comes over
and holds it out like that so the other
guests can't see devour his hand and
then the guy so my my girl was like I'm
not even a [ __ ] I'm not eating a
pigeon head but I'll eat everything I'll
eat everything what's the grossest thing
you've ever eaten
I ate a live cockroach that's I could
never do that I don't know what's worse
the pigeon head or the cockroach
cockroach live is tough guy actually I
think the pigeon I expect the Cockroach
more I did it on live TV for I actually
it it will come up eating cockroaches it
was me and Michelle Beadle
well that's not it uh
that's me getting a leech on my [ __ ]
yeah have you ever done the leeches
thing Brian I've had leeches all over my
body because I was in I was in uh I
would I would do Indonesia and I was in
the rainforest and you'd have to pull
the leashes off your they would not only
be on your legs they'd be they'd find
their way on your neck my sister my
sister was so freaked out yeah but I
didn't give a [ __ ] I just let him eat me
and this is us me and Michelle Beadle
eaten
is that a daddy Madagascar gas cockroach
or something is it a hissing one
now did the guy in the middle eat most
the roaches the the guy in the middle
was the he was the roach farmer the
people on the other guy who sits next to
me on Southwest people on the end this
I was doing a Naked and Afraid after
show so my deal was I was going to eat
whatever they had to eat on the show
[Applause]
so that's a that's a Madagascar hissing
Contour maybe cheers I watched the
episode I guess and they don't bite you
uh the guys
[Applause]
what's it taste like it tastes I can't
believe Michelle Beados to do it she's
not even paid for this no she wasn't
getting paid
Michelle Beadle she she's she's on radio
she's on podcast now she's the best
she's great she left yeah yeah she was
she was working one of the best
personality and she she's doing her own
thing now she's so [ __ ] good job but
I called her I go hey you want to come
here to some live bugs with me so before
the show
the guy this was my option because it
was a naked and afraid and and when we
were pitching like ideas on how to make
show interesting I was like you know
I'll they eat weird things on every show
so I'll eat when they come on the after
show I'll eat some of what they eat just
to kind of you know
and so on this show beforehand that dude
you saw the big guy in the middle he was
like here are the three options you can
eat cockroach
and he said the cockroach is the
cleanest thing you're going to eat
because it's organically raised farmed
and raised and I go yeah but they
shouldn't piss all over each other right
he's like that's the one better oh
maggots which was a hard pass for me one
small maggot a handful of maggots no no
I've eaten maggots roasted and they
taste like popcorn really tastes like
popcorn and the third one was this giant
caterpillar like a light blue and I go I
think I might eat that and he goes the
only problem I know what that is Juicy
the juice I know exactly what that he
said if you eat yeah it's gonna shoot
into the back of your throat [ __ ] you
yeah yeah yeah so my son had a bearded
dragon and you'd feed them those [ __ ]
yeah those [ __ ] are disgusting
but those they're juicy
hello their tongue I wasn't gonna eat
that but the Cockroach basically it was
kind of gross but it what was really
good is it kind of you remember that gum
freshen up that kind of exploded in your
mouth yeah that was the part that when
it kind of popped it was real gross but
it didn't taste like anything man it
tasted like I listen I'll still watch
old episodes of Fear Factor I'm like God
Crush all that athletic events but when
they do the eating thing I would lose in
a [ __ ] yeah like even when the liver
King came on here that liver I was
trying to be cool kids here I was
literally throwing it oh you had to eat
a testicle it's disgusting but that
school didn't bother me it was the liver
did you eat the testicle I had a Slither
of it it tastes like scallop and it's
what's the what's the idea with raw I'm
sorry for being really ignorant yeah why
the wrong the the idea behind raw is
that your the enzymes and everything are
untouched so it's not burning all that
yeah so you can digest it better but you
know
um so like apparently with raw milk
which I used to always drink because I
thought it was you know that within this
pasteurized milk your body kind of
pasteurizes it anyway it breaks it down
through heat and metabolizes it in a way
where it breaks it down into all its
different components anyway so I don't
know I've had food scientists guys like
land Norton who are like oh so so so my
buddy Andy Galvin who's a scientist at
Caltech
um bring up Andy Galpin he's like his
specialty is nutrition working with the
best athletes but does primary research
and he goes I said well liver is a
superfood and he goes who told you that
I go no because of the nutrients because
what nutrients what nutrients you're
gonna and I was like No And I start to
go through the new I'm trying to go
through the nutrients and he's basically
he's such a smart guy and he's such a
good guy he looks smart but he uh he
[ __ ] it was so funny that's not what
he looks like that's a weird picture but
it was so [ __ ] funny because he goes
yeah that is nutritious but so is a lot
of other food yeah like the same as like
a prime rib eye or flavor
maybe maybe not even vitamins
no push back on the on the idea of
superfoods right yes like it's true that
[ __ ] oysters are really really good
for you it's true that liver is really
good for you it's true but a lot of
foods are really good for you and you
find those nutrients in a lot of stuff
yeah so in other words if you never ate
liver but you ate muscle meat okay and
then you ate a regular diet the
multivitamin yeah you're just as healthy
and even when you go through these
things where they really want to see
what you're deficient in and stuff like
that the first thing they tell you when
they do that crazy blood work panel stop
taking all supplements we want to see
where you are I just did both about it
we want to see where you are and then
and then a lot of times they won't have
you take certain things it's like you're
fine with it yeah you might need this
and sometimes if you take for example
too much iron it can throw your body if
you overdo it yeah it's taking a little
break fellas I'm pretend they're here
this you won't believe they're still
taking poops so listen today's episode
of funk is brought to you by athletic
greens we talking ag1 by athletic greens
the category leading superfood product
brings comprehensive and convenient
daily nutrition for everybody keeping up
with the research knowing what to do
taking a bunch of pills and capsules
it's so 90s you don't have to worry
about that because with one tasty scoop
of ag1 you get 75 vitamins minerals
Whole Food Source ingredients including
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green food super blend we got you
covered man I use it every single
morning I start my day with aj1 Joe in
the movement of athletes podcasters
Comics Dads Moms rookies first timers
everyone taking this ag-1 all right to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you an immune supporting free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter right now again simply visit
athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give a.g-1 a
try athleticgreens.com fighter Last Read
final kid arm I swear we got to keep the
house lights on this episode of fine kid
with Josh wolves is also brought to you
by on it not just any product at audit
we're talking Alpha Brain today the
ultra nootropic the best nootropic the
world renowned nootropic supplement with
over 1 million bottles sold all right
Alpha Brain promotes cognitive functions
include memory mental speed and focus
can help you remember names zero on a
complex task and think more clearly
under stress uh our boy Joe Rogan says
it helps them form better sentences when
he's talking that's right be more like
Rogan Alpha Brain also caffeine free if
you worry about Jitters all that don't
worry about it it's caffeine free matter
of fact on it's so confident in Alpha
Brain you can get your money back if you
don't dig it just give them two weeks if
that point you feel like Alpha Brain is
gonna fit for you just tell them why and
they will refund your money on the spot
no return necessary keep it we don't
need it all right you can save temps off
your entire order on it not just on
Alpha Brain but the entire freaking
website by going to audit.com
f-a-t-k that's audit.com f-a-t-k save 10
off Alpha Brain a bunch of other cool
stuff at anna.com or if you just want
Alpha Brain swing by your local Walmart
pick some up today but you're not gonna
save 10 so use this code audit.com
f-a-t-k get you some Alpha Brain you're
welcome I I just did one of those for
the first time and was blown away and
what the guy said he was like he was
like look man think of your body as a
lot of different tanks yeah and you're
going to fill that tank up that means
you don't need to take that supplement
anymore as he said but what most people
do is they take one they just go oh this
is good for me I stay on and stay on it
and it's it's not doing yeah you're
already filled up so the one thing they
all think you should always take
um is creatine creatine we're gonna get
it from meat though yeah but you but
taking supplement and creatine is really
good for your brain I haven't heard and
yeah so so the the the the one thing
that I've everybody I've talked to
really studies this I'm talking about
the scientists not not you know the Bro
signs everyone of them says creatine is
the one the most researched supplement
you take it I do now because he told me
your brain creatine and uh fish oil I
take the fish oil do you take creatine
uh I used you should but because they
say it's really good for your brain yeah
but if I eat enough red meat it's in the
red meat yeah that's all you eat is
right yes
I I gotta tell you I don't know how you
should like if if I just only ate meat
can't do it I don't know if I would ever
[ __ ] no you do that's why Rogan was like
get ready man the the explosive diarrhea
they just never came yeah I never want
to have someone say that to me
get ready man sometimes
you know I feel the best when I eat fish
and and I eat vegetables you know I went
I've done a lot of it right now I'm
strict keto just to kind of see I've
never done it before but I've done I did
that 90 days of just beans greens nuts
and seeds where I went strict vegan
how'd you feel
hungry yeah I don't like that I didn't
like it not lethargic hungry
alert
um my skin never looked better but
Hillary Clinton bumper sticker on your
car
I got a biker I might putting this on I
bought two pant suits I uh but I feel
better now on the keto than I ever have
I had a I loved it I had [ __ ] elk
Burger today and blueberries oh
blueberries so so the other thing is
blueberries are [ __ ] amazing for you
they're like they're they're as close to
uh yeah they're they're a kind of a
nootropic they're really Superior brain
yeah but but uh the one thing that a lot
of people find uh a lot of these guys
who specialize in getting people getting
people's Health on track in terms of
looking at all the markers is some of
their biggest clients are people who
took testosterone without the
supervision of a doctor and what happens
is yeah so what happens is your dick's
house working afterwards they did no
post psychotherapy what are we talking
about because endocrine your endocrine
system is really delicate there's
certain things you can take to activate
your testes so your body's like all
right you're putting in fake
testosterone so they shut down yeah you
take cloma it's going to bring back a
lot of that there's a science like like
it's a real talking with your endocrine
system is yeah big time that's why
endocrinologists are real I mean it's
like it's a really complicated thing
because a lot of times they'll look at
your body and go let's talk about why
for example your cholesterol is high why
is your testosterone low what is it you
might be doing [ __ ] that is is ensuring
that to happen so they try to get you in
they look at all your markers and then
get you in the balance where you should
be and then if you're low they they
raise yourself take you a year but yeah
yeah it'll take a while
no no no just taking trt can can lead to
complications if you don't if you're not
setting your endocrine system are you
not are you not taking trt no I didn't
want them to why wouldn't you I just
have so much energy
not to be a dick but I I can [ __ ] every
night you know your test levels are
really high I just I mean you know I
feel good too man like I I I'm not
against it but dude I feel good I'm I'm
you know it's funny when you came and
did that episode of the show
I thought I was in better shape than I
was I was get new tire gas and I I
thought they brought me into you know
doing for Keeps oh dude so the show that
I shot with Jacob my son the one I sent
you an episode but we did a boxing
episode also oh nice and he came boxed
he came in with one of the judges
yeah oh you know if you're not breathing
dude I was [ __ ] gas and they were
they're one minute round one minute one
minute rest one minute
forget to breathe
debris on it and you don't know how to
relax but be some remember the first
time I boxed yeah Tony said I couldn't
breathe I had to stop yeah because I
couldn't I stopped breathing and he was
like yeah I was like [ __ ] I feel like a
[ __ ] he goes dude you just you weren't
breathing and that kid was really trying
to hit you so I was like the headset
[ __ ] you know what's funny is that like
so I'm boxing with Jacob my son and so
it's we're doing like 70 percent
bees are coaching Jacob like ripped
through the body he's an old man jab jab
rip I kept going rip through the body
take him out
and then I kept yelling I'm like this
[ __ ] kid's not listening he came back
four times hey dude that's my dad I went
okay I couldn't hear him I'm not gonna
hurt my [ __ ] daughter
they have the camera then why would you
call me why did you call me coach dude
yeah we're in the ring and I can hear
him like [ __ ] Mick and Rocky rip
through the body ripped through the body
jab jab I wanted to hold him in the
liver on he kept saying Yeah he
delivered
and finally Jacob's like hey calm the
[ __ ] down dude I was like all right all
right I'm not gonna hit my dad yeah
somebody's actually hitting you back and
you haven't done it dude you're gonna
guess I guessed out quick I don't care
if you're a triathlete it's hot in there
too that's the other thing because we
had to turn the air off for the filming
are you taking a trt not you know I am
not anti no I'm not at all I'm not anti
but right now like actually I want to
see where I'm at I'm dying to see now
where my levels are in every way are you
joking about all that [ __ ] yeah doing it
all I want to see I bet it's pretty high
I just didn't naturally well yeah but if
it's not I'm I can't you take a lot of
naps on the road
so I had my whoop and I get very good
sleep what's a whoop this this thing is
the band that tells you how accurate is
it really accurate I don't know I assume
so well I my my uh my sleep is like my
home is really good yeah yeah my sleep
is good I guess that didn't mean if I
test levels no but I mean I think when I
so here's here's what I I would say if I
get seven and a half hours of sleep
I don't need a nap and I'm I'm energized
all day and then I crash at about 12. I
I took like two and a half grams of
mushrooms last night that's a lot of
that's a lot of mushrooms I enjoy it uh
but it is
keeps me entered like
it keeps me energized for the next day
now when you take two and a half grams
of mushrooms what time do you start that
this is fascinating I'm I love
psychedelics but when you take two and a
half grams of mushrooms
where what are you capable of doing can
you do I want to tell you anything oh I
did a two-hour podcast last night on
mushrooms yep
by yourself
I would love to do that with you you
guys should older guys should do that
the older guys that's what we'll call
that podcast
Josh and Brian dude show the older I
would love to do that with you dude uh
100 I know it is right what's that he's
gonna [ __ ] each other
you're like dude these these mushrooms
make you feel like
why are you all weird about mushrooms no
I just don't want to do it I want you to
talk
I want you to do mushrooms why don't you
do two grams I have some money
I I have some delicious
mushroom caramel candies in my bag you
too I love candy yeah
Josh do you remember you remember last
summer at The Comedy Store and you took
too many mushrooms and shake your pants
oh well dude I so I hey that happened so
I get on stage and he goes I'm sit I'm
watching I forget who's on stage and he
comes
dude I'm like what's up he's on I'm so
[ __ ] up
I took way too many mushrooms man and I
was like he's I don't know what the [ __ ]
I go on next I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing Josh I'm done good thing
you've been doing this for 30 years
I didn't actually [ __ ] my pants but
totally
so I I told Sammy Tripoli I'm like hey
dude I gotta go to the bathroom real bad
because mushroom poops are immediate and
explosive I'm like I can't bring this on
stage just kind of energy let me go poop
he goes you got five minutes so I go in
I poop in that back room of the in the
main room you don't frown the pond it's
frowned upon but there was no yeah it
had happened yeah and so
I pull my pants up I go back out not a
clean toilet okay
a day later I fly from LA to Orlando
I am getting ready for a show that
Thursday night
I decide I'm like you know what I really
like those pants that I wore
I take him out there is chocolate [ __ ]
listen not on the inside on the outside
of my pants above my [ __ ] oh no okay
right above my [ __ ] on the outside
below the so here's what happened lava
[ __ ] here's what's crazy so terrible
here's what's crazy not only did I do
two shows one of The Comedy Store I
wanted to laugh at you had [ __ ] on your
pants Not only was I Around All of You
Not only was I in four Ubers nobody
nobody wanted to say hey dude you got
some [ __ ] on you we're all in our own
world
I also I also don't I'm not looking for
[ __ ] you smell it you might smell it
didn't smell [ __ ] I mean it was terrible
dude but the fact that I pulled it out
and my wife was there and I held it up
she was like what is that I'm like I
think that's poop she was like what
why do you have poop on the outside of
your pants I'm like I because I do
mushrooms and there's there's nothing
there's nothing sexy about poop
you know I wear Whitey tight literally I
don't wear Whitey tights I wear tighty
whities but they're not white I always
have dark colors for you know yeah I
don't want people stains in streets yes
my girl is like oh you need new
underwear she bought the white ones I'm
like I'm telling you I'm telling you I'm
trying to be cool keep it sexy yeah you
don't want me wearing the white one no
that's why I go hey I look like it's
like I'm on the Spectrum when I wear
these B it's a disaster I'm trying to
keep it sexy don't you clean yourself
yeah I do but after you poop but still
it's you know it should happen
it just happens yeah I told her don't I
do but it's all I had I wore the white
ones for one day she did the laundry
she's like oh here we go oh my God I'm
like I [ __ ] told you there's a reason
why I wear camo colored undies [ __ ]
yeah I mean also get rid of them get rid
of them throw them I told you you're
playing with fire throw them away or buy
now she won't touch or buy 300 150 pair
and I'll wear them and throw them away
after everything you want to do that
yeah or apparently Eddie Murphy does
that or he wears he has Eddie Griffin
used to do that with his sneakers did
you ever hear about that he uses so once
throws it away he's a German he would
also do only your Force Ones who's in
his rider yeah you'd have the brand new
Clean Air Force that's called being a
dick do you have you ever just
considered finding out why your [ __ ]
leaks
probably so I'm lazy I'll take I don't
think I need to go to a doctor I'll take
a look I mean is it leaking like like a
steady drip or is it just like no it's
just like he doesn't because he wipes
he's a lazy wiper and he does you know I
need I need a bidet yeah one of those
new ones that spray up problem with that
is once it you're down there I chill if
there's a nice bidet some of the hotels
have them yeah I'm there for hours but
why not just grab some wipes toilet
toilet paper is
um primitive and but the wipes are
disgusting the wipes are great yeah
I I need water on my [ __ ] and I keep
it really pristine oh dude after that
nice restaurants or hotels I'll walk in
he's in the restaurant on top of the
sink going like this that's the water
it's not true you know it just stuck my
ass in a sink before yes doing this with
the water and I'm like what no your ass
is to me which is worse because in your
big balls you're just hanging down he's
going like this
oh they're massive yeah I have huge
balls that's probably why my test
they're so plump really yeah
and a dick my dick hangs low lower than
your let me ask you no no way your
dick's not lower than dude my dick is no
his balls his balls are like those big
white truffles they brought oh my girl
the other day goes look at your
situation I'm like I know I'm just a I
got a big old lazy dick and balls did
you like that you think you have your
work cut out for it for the rest of your
life is it top heavy I got a dick
Brian has a dick on it he knows big
balls
I told Brian when he was let me ask you
a question I told Brian he's starting to
only fans and just [ __ ] nut shots nut
shots dick two questions for you one how
how far in the future are you gonna have
to hold your hands and your balls and
your hands so you don't poop on them how
how far in the future is that I'll work
it there okay it's not hanging that low
I don't think so okay no no it's not
like an old low it's just like these big
Grandpa like a heavy it's like it's like
a baboon thing it's so strange because I
remember my grandfather saying to me
again if I was gay they'd be delicious
it's weird
it almost looks painful yeah you know
with liver King enjoy like is that the
size of Note we're talking about well
you know he had a bull test go and I
thought it was a bull heart I don't know
it was a it was [ __ ] like this where
do you size of an ostrich egg where do
you buy where does he go in
this Chef has the easiest job in the
world because you're gonna have to cook
it just cuts he just yeah is he as short
as I think he is yes five seven I was
more because online he likes [ __ ]
Jack and doing it wrong he's in really
good shape and big but he's not like a
massive you know he's about five seven
five six five seven yeah but in really
good shape yeah yeah dude I mean look at
him he he's smells like a tent but
right uh he's got a game he sent but
it's not like horrible I have to tell
you
but if I looked at him and you were like
do you think he smells good I'd be like
no I don't I think that's beard smells
terrible it smells wild yeah yeah like
one of the Lost Boys there's a scent of
the wild yeah absolutely not when he's
sitting there but when he if he hugs you
you're like all right there's a there's
a wild it's the kind of scent a woman
who's into primitive that was rock hard
getting tired I had the whole time whole
time no he's like he was a a Charming
dude so you were really down there it's
like naturally good person silly silly I
love watching the silly the silly goose
he's aware like it's like everybody else
is putting all the stuff on the guy and
the guy's like Hey listen [ __ ] face I'm
making a million dollars a year and I
and I have a supplement company and I
fly privately and I have a great family
life and I eat raw and I'm just
promoting health so yeah you may
disagree but whatever and he's not an
extremist he's like I eat liver I also
eat honey and fruit and also if I'm out
to a good meal I'll have whiskey yeah he
was like one in Rome he had whiskey with
he drank Tigers if you took him to
dinner he'd be like what do we have
pasta let's do it if he's not he's not
that dude but it's part of the Persona
like yeah yeah again like a professional
wrestler he's promoting a healthy
lifestyle though so people hate on him
he just said it yeah that's right he's
Hulk Hogan yeah but he eats raw Bowl
nuts
he's also funny he's also like I had my
Invisalign against Invisalign so Primal
I enjoyed him he was hilarious you gotta
love him all right all right Tim what do
you
got
alrighty let's see which one's good here
chin you you have you got trouble okay
so here's some breaking news if I was
getting texts you know from the group
and stuff like this out look up Alex
Jones the the settlement came in oh it's
only like a billion dollars or something
a billion yeah I got a voice note from
wait a buddy that we all know and yeah
he owns like a billion dollars yeah
and and can I read you what Chris said
to the group chat what christalia said
he goes Brendan will be like he has that
in his wallet you know how much money he
makes he made 14 billion last week
is that accurate or not were you going
to say that the one thing I had dinner
with Alex Jones I was telling I'm like
dude you're [ __ ] you're on the hook
for 60 million he was like well wait can
we get the Alex Jones impression because
I when you do your Alka Jones he was
like he's like man look he's like here's
things
he's all here's the thing Brad he's like
yes it says 60 million dollars he's like
the most you can pay in the state of
Texas five million I mean 20 million I'm
supplemented it's like okay yeah he's
still one yeah
but in Connecticut when they do that
when you owe a billion dollars the truth
is there's a cap you only have to pay 10
million of that well hold on that's only
in the state of Texas yeah but
Connecticut too has that so find out so
they're gonna say a bill in it in the
headlines like Yo Yo's a billion dollars
why but there's a cap on how much you
have to pay out to these families but so
is that just for show then to say the
billion is it like why not just say what
he's actually gonna have yeah I don't
know question so the reason they do that
now this is also according to Alex Jones
so I I didn't know that damage this what
is the capital punitive damages and
you'll see in the same thing there you
go so the truth is he's probably out 20
million dollars or 10 million dollars a
lot of money by the way but yeah a lot
of money but it's not a billion it says
tuck this law could keep him so go back
to because they get they get to him go
back go back yeah go back and right
where it says uh so this 1995 Texas log
could Shield Alex Jones from paying the
vast majority of the 50 million
defamation case you see it yeah yep
click on that
and
um Texas Jury has a word nearly 50
million judgment in defamation trial
against extremist talk show host
Alex Jones all right yep the question uh
27 all right uh so he could be forced to
pay less than five million total damages
yes that's from the 50 million judgment
though yeah yeah now go to Connecticut
and if you go to Connecticut
and so different state is different how
much you there's a cap on how much you
have to pay it just seems crazy to me
that you would
say the billion if that's not if it's
just for show like
what the [ __ ]
I bet you it'll tell you in that I know
probably if I just click on the article
yeah nah but you're gonna get NBC Yahoo
they're not going to give you a real
breakdown of it because they they want
to make it look like yeah it's
destroying them yeah you don't want to
type in Alex Jones
we want the real real chin
[Music]
I'd rather watch that bow and arrow
video hold on right here it does look so
important
it's like those those historians that do
primary research and look through all
the Scrolls in Aramaic and Greek you're
like I you can shoot myself dig them up
in some dusty [ __ ] sky's the limit
there it is a 50-state survey of Damages
caps what about that sky's the limit 55
damages caps are there limits to
punitive damages in Connecticut look oh
my goodness Alabama 2 million here
Connecticut does not cap does not cap so
okay that's gonna be a problem now maybe
they went so hard on them because they
knew he's paying the cap in Texas so
connect it was like hold our [ __ ]
internet oh two separate trials one in
Connecticut and one in Texas Connecticut
Sandy Hook's where the shooting took
place right yeah it's not good yeah that
one that only could be tough for him
yeah a billion right that's gonna make
it go think no I think it's still like
10 million or no you don't know though
right because we just looked at it it
says No Cap he was saying no he didn't
say Connecticut yeah he did oh did he
yeah I'm sure his lawyers I don't know
that's yeah he didn't seem
terribly worried about really yeah but I
mean I think what's worrying is that you
you walk around and people hate you
and you know you you don't get away with
that behavior
you don't get away with uh you know I
was I I remember being so outraged by
that those children were killed yeah and
those parents are going through the
worst nightmare anybody who has parents
my kids were I think about that age
and I think unimaginable yeah and when
someone not only says that but also
there are [ __ ] followers who are the
people out there who actually start to
buy into it and start harassing their
parents and don't stop attacking [ __ ]
online so you're going through that and
they're coming to your house and they're
calling your your phone I'm calling you
an actor and a liar I'll just show them
yeah so this is so this is Revenge is
best served as a dish best service right
like you can I I can understand the
anger and the insanity because and I and
I don't dislike Alex Jones I like Alex
Jones I think he's been writing a lot of
stuff but this is the one and you know
Rogan agrees with this this is the one
where it's like you went too far dude
and I think he realized any parent
realized that I don't know anybody like
well no but but here's the thing like
with something like this it's hard for
me to go you know you go he was right on
a bunch of things I can't look past this
about it this one's bad there's no I've
never been able to look back if you're a
parent too I think most parents
understand right [ __ ] mind yeah I
agree if somebody
shot my kid and then this [ __ ] I
would be at his house everyone agrees
with that and that's that's what
happened and so
you know and in a sense you could say
that's an example of where conspiracy
theories are damaging you have to be
careful yeah you have to be careful with
how you speak and I'm sure he regrets it
100 and I don't think that I don't think
that Alex Jones is a I don't know him
well I've only met him a couple times
but I don't think he's an evil person I
think that he is somebody who found
either two things one is he found a
great deal of success in painting the
World As Good Guys bad guys bad Elites
who who drink the blood of children and
everybody else is the best of all time
yeah any any post that any any pits it
the narrative is a Biblical narrative
right I read his book recently
um which I don't agree with yeah but but
but um but then the other thing is that
he may very well look at the world that
way and and he may be that's the guy who
actually believes a lot but I'd be
willing to bed just sitting down with
Alex Jones if you brought one of those
dads who lost their son it was like hey
stop stop stop just do me favorite just
talk this guy over coffee for a second
yeah if the dad's open to it yeah I'm
saying this is before he went on his
rants about this handy hook and if you
have sat down that dad there's like oh
there's no way he's an actor but here's
you could feel the pain yeah like those
dads and the parents give them the
testimonies to Alex Jones I had to turn
off I'm like I can't watch this yeah
like you can just I didn't see the tear
the the pain too of these pants you're
like oh my God it never goes away Bob no
you know it's like that's oh that'd be
the one thing I'd get I remember my
buddy said that to me Jimmy Burke said I
was trying to console somebody who had
lost their uh husband and uh
and he said Brian sometimes there's
something called inconsolable grief
that's what you came across and I was
like [ __ ] man [ __ ] that's right there's
no coming back no no zero okay yeah
there's zero coming back what else you
gotcha all right I'm hurt I'm sure you
heard last week that Kanye West's
Twitter I guess multiple like social
media accounts got closer I'm about to
go Defcon
uh I'm a bit sleepy tonight when I wake
up I'm gonna go Defcon 3 on Jewish
people the funny thing is I actually
can't be anti-semitic because black
people are actually Jew also uh you guys
have told me you guys have toyed with me
and tried to blackball anyone who ever
opposes your agenda if there's one thing
every celebrity should know by now it's
the one group of people you don't want
to piss off are the Jews let me tell you
my people it's just not the ones you
want to [ __ ] with me because they run
the world I will tell you this man it
all as a Jew I will say it is also more
acceptable
if that if you had taken Jews and put in
Asians blacks women
this dude would be in deep [ __ ] but Jews
it just feels like ah I mean this is the
one thing where finally Instagram and
Twitter and stuff took them off okay
casual anti-Semitism casual
anti-Semitism is more more acceptable
measure it in different ways I think
that I think that the larger threat is
that the Jews make up look up how many
Jews make up 0.02 percent of the
population in the world that's right if
you want to talk about a true minority
it's the Jews but then you can also say
this let me let me tell you the most
successful yes but let me tell you
anti-Semitism is just below the surface
everywhere I know the time and it takes
one little one little spark and history
proves that over and over so if the Jews
hear that and they don't speak up right
away through experience and galvanized
you die you die you know they were
talking about this guy was talking about
um how the Mossad is the most most
ruthless uh they'll do whatever it takes
well that's because they're dealing with
life and death they're not dealing amen
they're dealing with life and death they
live in a country they live in a they
live in a country where they're
surrounded by other countries that want
to wipe them off the face of the Earth
all of Europe does too so the the rise
in anti-Semitism now it's crazy in
Hungary in Bulgaria in in Poland and in
everywhere is is never been higher and
yes we've seen these Trends and what
happens what happens when economies
tank watch yeah as economy start tank
Watch What Happens in Germany Germany's
in real trouble what what happens is it
becomes very convenient to blame
International Bankers you'll hear the
words you'll hear globalists you'll hear
International blank bankers
that is that is always code I promise
you for Jews yeah of course it is and do
they go after them because of the most
successful minority because they're so
good at business so a lot of it is if
you look at the leaders of business so
the owners of BlackRock and things like
that a lot of them are Jewish if you
look at the people the leaders of
thought in business and different things
like that and especially in finance
sometimes and the people behind the
political machines these strategists and
stuff uh a lot of them are Jewish so
entertainment tooth heads of yes
journalism right journalism right
journalism and things like that so
Academia Academia a lot of the leaders
of thought and Academia and it's never
been different so that's never been
different well you guys are crushing it
and and the people at the Forefront of
social change historically so let me
give you a stat in this country during
the Civil Rights Movement half the white
volunteers half the white volunteers who
marched and got hoses turned on were
Jewish and they made up less than less
than half point five percent of the
population United States and the reason
for that is that the Jews have always
been at the Forefront of social change
always but there's been a because
there's been a level of persecution
throughout history well it's not just
persecution genocide yeah yeah and even
God himself in the Old Testament said
I'm done with you [ __ ] people get out
of here and he scattered them every
[ __ ] literally said get out of here I
think he called them heaves so he took
the 12th I'm done with you heaps yes so
he took the 12th president and he
scattered them in the earth and he said
I turned my back on you even Moses he
said Moses his most faithful follower in
the Old Testament he goes hey you didn't
[ __ ] believe in me completely and you
[ __ ] second guess me so guess what I
told you to hit that rock once to get
water and you hit it twice you didn't
quite believe me completely so your
punishment even though you've served me
is you don't get to see the promised
land you'll get to see it from a
Mountaintop but you're gonna die
in the desert
listen man that's a house of dragons
of dragons and you know what you know
what God made Moses do to his own
brother Aaron is that [ __ ] this
is unbelievable he said take Aaron
you're who is also Moses brother was
very faithful to the god of Israel he
said don't like him he uh he didn't like
that I had made he he second guessed my
choosing you as the leader of the of the
Israelites God said God said to Moses he
he is rumbling about the fact that I
don't favor him over you I don't like
his level of Faith so here's what you're
gonna do take him take Aaron and Aaron's
son to the top of I think it's Mount
Moab I believe in Utah and no
in the desert in China yeah
and he goes like this he goes he goes
right he goes and he said this is what
God said he goes take Aaron's clothes
off take all his clothes off
on the top of the mountain where it's
freezing take his clothes off give him
to his son and then you and his son
leave and they left him up there to die
and then the Israelites mourn for 40
days all in the Bible kids
wow so to be one of God's chosen people
was not exactly that much fun can I tell
you a very good person when I was in
South Carolina it would mean that God
God may have chosen you as a chosen one
but boy that's a [ __ ] lot to deal
with because that God the god of the
Israelites was not a very strict
he'd be like hold on I don't like you
guys when they said we wanted we want to
choose a King David or Solomon or the
book of Samuel the guy was like hold on
you guys have a king it's me I gave you
the Commandments yeah you want a king
okay cool you wanna you wanna a king on
earth oh good hey Assyrians Babylonians
Persians come on down here raise the
temple in Jerusalem take all the Jews
and bring them back as slaves then 50
years later the Judas realized like Hey
we're [ __ ] sorry it'd be like you
guys sure all right bring him back yo
that first testament God was a
[ __ ] yeah I'm giving dude this
book sounds lit can I tell you something
the Old Testament is crazy South
Carolina this is how casual this is how
casual some anti-Semitism getting when I
was in South Carolina meet and greet
dude walks up to me and we've taken a
picture armor arm around me and as he's
smiling for the picture he was like you
know I usually don't think you people
are that funny
and I went um
I go you people and he started to laugh
at his friends he goes you know kites
with a T he called me a kite Heights not
a [ __ ] yeah a kite yeah and I was like
say it again he was like kite I hope
that's not offensive I go nah not
offense you yeah we're good yeah it's so
stupid by the way I didn't correct him
no because if you're calling Jews kites
in South Carolina yeah I'm okay I'm not
upset by that do you know what I mean
matter of fact keep doing it yeah yeah
and they got to take a picture and he
goes I said something like you want to
take a you want to do a selfie because
he goes no what am I a Jew and he walked
away and I was like is that our
characteristics
just a dick just a guy who's just
looking to [ __ ] just wanted to spread
bad [ __ ] everywhere but I will like I
must have been a fan though because you
don't like this you came to my show most
Jewish person you know like yeah he came
to the show now I've only been
by the way you don't look Jewish is a
really nice way of saying your nose is
pretty good I look more juicy
I look more Jewish than you do I get it
all the time yeah
because of it what yeah because they
were talking about and it was some
holidays coming up like yo what are you
doing for what I was like what is it
like yeah I'm Jewish and I was like no
they're all thank you for your time I
was like ah [ __ ] yeah you can I convert
and come back you can we'll take it I'll
do it yeah we'll take it Dominic Are You
snipped you already cut up yeah but the
juice
right circumcision has got to be the
weirdest thing in the world that was
that was Moses way of showing God he was
subservient let me cut my dick I will
cut the poor skin off my [ __ ] I also
think it looks better I do too but we're
also conditioned to that because right
if they never cut it by the way go ahead
and post something about circumcision
online oh my God it's oh is it toxic oh
my [ __ ] I had no idea how crazy people
get it is mutilation that's the
mutilation and all this me and my girl
biggest fight whoever got it really I
didn't want to circumcise the kids how
come you didn't but you're circumcised
yeah okay but how come you didn't want
to circumcise him because it's a
religious thing I'm not religious right
to 100 religious thing but then also in
society now it's like you know she was
like well they're gonna play sports
probably you know so fit in the locker
room they have the hoods on you know
those kids are treated I'm like yeah but
but it's very interesting 2035 yeah it's
also a very interesting it's an
interesting practice it feels better
yeah it's a weird practice and then the
doctor feels but the the having a hood
it's more natural because the nerve
endings
that's what people say that have the
wizard sleeve do they get that little
Bazooka Joe turtleneck yeah chin has it
I have it yeah you do I think because I
was born in Korea too Shin's 100 organic
baby 100 organic fast food right I told
these how to raise most of Europe
doesn't circumstance right but the
doctor was like because you know he saw
me and my girlfriend he can't talk real
quick I'm like sure and I what was his
he goes dude do you remember I'm like no
that's your argument he was well what we
do is we give him sugar the first time
and as we give them the sugar then we
cut it I'm like oh and he's like so they
don't feel like what baby told you that
yeah what baby told you that I could
tell you also talking eat this lollipop
I'm gonna cut your dick you tell me if
you don't think well I want to tell him
yeah they numb the skin but yeah they
put a cream on it but I but I wouldn't
tell the doctor Are you seriously it's
not hey I'm gonna give you a [ __ ]
Starburst I'm gonna cut your hood up
yeah you tell me if it hurts but clean
but the same [ __ ] but I honestly it's
trauma for the baby shower wise
for honestly for me part of it I think
it's probably just easier less to clean
up all the time probably oh yeah pull
that hood back really good you have to
clean your dick anyway right yeah
literally I don't have to take the
turtle
you don't do that it depends on how much
you did two hands like this like it
depends on how much skin you have some
people have a lot of skin I don't have
that much skin so literally when I have
a hard dick my girl or my girlfriends at
the time they couldn't tell and they
they never saw my dicks you know by the
way we got into this we always get in
this we've gotten just because
it's like this and you just washed but
isn't it weird because you're not used
because you didn't grow up with the hood
and I didn't see any kids growing up
with me neither so when I'm watching
porno as a hood I'm like okay next right
next
that's not for you because they
recommended trans boy now it's the hood
it's like who the [ __ ] is doing this
alcohol dude there should be there
and she grew up so she has she's one of
the only women I'd know who's like
you're from Europe you grow up my wife's
German and uh she has the comparison
growing up with guys we're all
uncircumcised oh yeah and then coming
over here she seems to prefer at least
she says I don't even but also the one
who would be the kind of girl to
criticize your dick if she wanted to
um circumcised penises and you've got a
circumcised yes did she say why you got
a deep voice you working with a piece
working with a piece here yes um I
figured you would be you'll have to
you'll have to ask around I was gonna
say my mom stopped doing like she to my
little brother didn't get him
circumcised because I've made so much
noise during it so this whole idea oh my
God you know he was like after I heard
you scream or cry or whatever that
doctor's like he's good we gave him a
lollipop who's next he's not so me and
my older brother are circumcised and my
younger brother's not because you're
poisonous she was like you probably got
roasted as a kid yeah like in the locker
yeah football see you there was one kid
who was on certain size he wore a towel
the whole time lit up but then how come
you weren't gonna circumcise you how
come you didn't want to circumcise your
kids because I I realize it's just a
religious thing an interaction I think I
don't know I don't give a [ __ ] Trend or
not I don't want to hurt my kid the
first day in the world yeah because I
can't even see my kid get a shot if they
start crying oh they can't bring me the
worst can I can't bring me I think it
was getting like an MRI and they had all
this and he was scared to go I'm like we
ain't doing it to this day one of the
hardest things I ever saw Jacob wolf my
son was probably three years old and
they had to x-ray maybe two they had to
x-ray his long lungs and it x-ray your
lungs you got to put the kid in like
this and then you gotta shut him in a
glass they freaked the [ __ ] and
the guy's like listen man
super uncomfortable it's going to pinch
his skin that's how tight is going to be
they have no was it pneumonia he's like
he's gonna Cry he's gonna scream you
were going to see him in a way that's
going to be really uncomfortable for you
but no you he's gonna be looking at you
keep it cool
and dude and he started screaming Dad
Dad don't let him Dad Dad right and
right right away your instinct is dead
is like [ __ ] this we're done uh we're
good but to watch that I couldn't watch
it it's like when the kids
same tiger he had pneumonia yeah they
wanted to double check and the doctor
like good chance but we're just gonna
put them in the thing same thing he put
him in he starts going daddy you know I
went no no no listen let's let's go
ahead and pretend he has I'll sign
whatever you need yeah give me the [ __ ]
all right the medication we're not doing
this my girl's like no I have to do this
I'm like I'm first you don't have to do
it because they make money I'm telling
you we're not doing it yes and then it's
not they build the insurance guy was
like it's not happening they do yeah
yeah Aussie let's go ahead and pretend
he has pneumonia and you give us the
antibiotics and then we're getting the
[ __ ] out of it if you don't want to give
them I have a way to get them yeah [ __ ]
off yeah this ain't happening yep he was
like we can't go anymore that's fine
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off and you're trying to
make money off my kid in somewhere yeah
that's all your hospitals are like we'll
put them in again he goes well there's a
good chance he has no money I'm like
[Laughter]
because the air he popped out too
quickly so the water didn't come out of
his lungs and I was like do we have to
do this she was like you do have to do
this no certain times yeah I was like
all right what do I [ __ ] know what
else you got Jen what else you got by
the way my my dick is thicker because I
have extra skin when you pull it back
okay
all right whatever just wanted to wrap
that up I've seen something how thick is
your dick skin holy [ __ ] like a rhinos
even if you had like a millimeters
[Applause]
I brought that up because Kim Kardashian
this I think this happened probably
before he got taken off uh I think I
don't know if he had taken off Instagram
I know he had taken off Twitter yeah so
Kanye had beef with that guy boozy
badass and posted this message because I
guess boozy didn't like the whole White
lives matter stuff
and they went back and forth so Kanye
posted this
hold up
hold on yeah Kanye post now I'm back to
shoot the school up so look at the whole
thing though says don't don't speak on
me little boozy speak to me yeah Little
Nerd ass me come smack gonna smack me or
come shoot me I'm the one that got
bullied by the entire black celebrity
Community now I'm back to shoot the
school up so he's making a he's not
saying no he's saying he's he's now he's
coming back to Hollywood yeah bullied
school kid obviously
Kim Kardashian is now paying for extra
security at their school the kids school
not because she thinks Kanye is going to
do something but someone will read this
yeah and try to do something yeah he's a
massive fan base but this dude is
mentally ill dude definitely without a
doubt well also his grammar like I don't
know what he he's rambling he's mentally
he's interviewing Tucker Carlson though
not the same town as this like no he's
but he's smart and crazy I got you I got
family going to that same school so
he's he's mentally ill yeah like that
the interview on Tucker Carlson
furthered my belief that he's mentally
ill and just because he sounds eloquent
he's a he's mentally ill like you can
see when he's off at his meds this kind
of [ __ ] dude this is craziness you know
what I mean this kind of rambling and
all victim [ __ ] and no accountability
like he's also a billionaire he I think
he's I think part of it is like crazy
like a fox he's like watch me Trend you
know for sure but boy like white lives
matter and all that Pro like it's like
interesting you're like all right Connie
said something interesting on Tucker
Carlson because his dad
um he didn't have a relationship with
him growing up his mom moved from
Atlanta Chicago and his dad his mom was
like don't come here you never see him
again so he just thought his Dabs out of
the picture but his dad was told don't
come wow so he didn't have any
communication with him yeah really so
then he gets older reaches out to his
dad looks into his dad his dad's a
really smart guy and was part of the
Black Panther Movement right it was a
big time Black Panther Party Guy and so
his dad he goes when I wore the White
lives matter shirt he was the first
person to take something like that he's
a black panther and his dad goes white
lives matter hilarious and kind of goes
yeah it was kind of a joke too to be
polarizing I thought it was funny too
why did you think it was funny and the
dad who's a black panther goes because
of course White lives matter
he's like but everyone's up in you know
in such an uproar over this white lives
matter shirt
he's just he's just a fireman yeah he's
just he knows how to set [ __ ] things
a fire
that one's too far that I'm usually I'm
a Kanye fan that one about the school
too far too yeah a little bit weird
especially when you have you know those
crazy fans and they're stupid enough to
look at that go okay what school yeah
you're dealing with on mentally ill
people which is you know it's not good
let's see a woman get gored by a boss
already oh oh by the way I saw this
video it's kind of crazy I'll show you
the video first
a buck just came into the garage area
and look at this put I'm where is this
Montana's Wyoming
so
why did the buck fall now the little
dog's gonna try to protect oh
now she's trying to protect the dog she
gets gored here
and I guess that's her husband that
guy's just he's like okay well let's
just okay let's control the [ __ ]
antlers oh that's he's an old dude
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER dog right yo this this dude needs to
get out of there but she's annoying and
also that she was so addicted look at
that deer that dude
is so cold is like what the [ __ ] has
happened
that wiener dog tried ripping my [ __ ]
wet nose off but fell asleep
where did the where'd the deer stumble
out of he looked like me too in his
garage drunk no he was just like chin
coming out that jelly roll box yeah out
of the garage it fell out of her brush
look how it came out here yeah it's like
whoa there's something wrong with that
deer he's not well no it's slippery
because it's probably coming to the
garage the garage floor they can't get
traction he has Hooves on also she
didn't get gourd also that little dog
was fine no so the hospital she went to
the hospital she had seven punctures oh
really yeah so it's probably like really
not like huge punctures yeah I'll [ __ ]
you up
my favorite part look how many times he
pulls the door handle here and he goes
would you open this and quit yeah he's
like should I get the dog she's annoying
out of me
one two three four five four deer yeah I
wanted her to get I wanted to get a
quarter a little bit more not in a bad
way but just to shut her up like right
in the right in the ass to be fair those
guys got stabbed at Chris Delia's show
and bought merch went to the bar
this is true meanwhile this lady he
phoned in he found he called him in the
show and said what's up girl you know
what's interesting is that uh the vast
vast majority of people who have long
coveted and uh things like chronic
fatigue are are
middle-aged women white women really I'm
not kidding I'm not kidding they're
middle-aged white women and usually
middle and middle class to upper class
they get longer no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] right but no [ __ ] [ __ ] hey Brian
can I just ask what are you implying
with that statement middle class and
upper class white women are you tell me
uh older white women to have a ton of
energy they're older white women if they
get in positions of power can [ __ ] a lot
of stuff up is what I'm trying to say
let me just say do you think this was a
long covered situation that's why yes I
do I was just saying that she was
screaming well after recording was over
and it's just screaming over here going
what are you saying that didn't help the
situation
do you think that's the husband yeah
poor guy you think that guy was married
that's why he was well die by deer then
deal with that [ __ ] yeah it's also
Wyoming right I would have thrown myself
on that [ __ ] deer's antlers I would
have been like I can't take it I would
have just thrown myself on the antlers
no he went like this he was all yeah I
think he ran out of energy and I locked
the car kind of a strong old man I did
he one-armed it
no he was like this and then he went the
thing's pretty strong unlock the car he
pulled that door handle like seven years
he was just like this he was like oh
[ __ ] that thing's a live animal hey get
off with the car hey get off my wife get
off my [ __ ]
make a noise well no he cares him enough
to get one hand on them he was just like
uh sideways hey hey stop stop relax but
he did pick up that little wiener dog
love you honey yeah he cared more about
the wiener dog so did she there's no way
that they were married he's like that he
did say it did say husband in the
article hey dude
my wife is 33 years old I'm 50. she
wasn't young either that's
it how old are you well five 55.
how old are you 53.
what else you got Jen got okay [ __ ]
annoying it's fantastic wait I want to
see the honey badger fight three left
okay we'll do that one next Honey Badger
fights three leopards fights what honey
badger badass they don't [ __ ] around
dude no they're nervous what
honey badgers this is a good metaphor
for life oh no what's the metaphor Brian
Josh you know about the famous funny
Badger videos that thing's all [ __ ] up
right two of them grabbed yeah two of
them grabbed the honey badger
it's a minute and 50 SEC a minute 56
seconds long
this one gets one
no it gets free goes after that guy
these cheese is like cheers
that's a mother in her Cubs
but she was like I'm not even doing it
I'm just standing here watching bro my
mother's my mom's dumb ass idea I think
it's gonna die though no and leopard
will [ __ ] it up hold on
they are tough Badgers are tough honey
badgers especially which one Brian is
the better I forget is it the jaguar or
the leopard that's the hunter while the
Jaguar is a three okay that's the one
right that can climb the trees
Jaguars are in the Amazon they're 300
pounds yes and a Jaguar is about two
times two so sometimes heavier than a
leopard leopard and what do we call
black jaguars Panthers and they climb
trees with like antelopes in there oh
yeah most of the leopards but but
Jaguars will climb will climb a tree
with a [ __ ] human with a human or a
caiman a basically a crocodile oh back
to archery
actually it was an accident that's what
the honey badge are needed
up so check this out this uh this dude
with Down Syndrome was with Wendy's for
about 20 years and was just let go they
didn't tell him why at first and his
sister said that he doesn't even know he
was fired so he thinks he's retiring so
they're just throwing it away that's
awesome right so hey Wendy's be [ __ ]
cool man why are we firing now to be
fair but if you worked there long enough
clearly knew how the business works but
uh I had a kid I worked he had Down
syndrome at when my first job when I was
a janitor at a grocery store and the kid
was a bagger he had you know he was 40
something and he just [ __ ] things up
like he would take their bread and then
put the cans of soda on top of it yeah
but no one wanted to say anything they'd
be like no that's fine yeah anyway can I
walk it out for you like sure and he's
like do you know over and [ __ ]
eventually they're like hey dude do you
remember a show called life goes on yes
the guy named Corky my cousin Scott and
I were extras on that one day
and there was a scene where Corky had to
walk down half of a hallway is set in
high school turn a corner and walk down
the other hallway one continuous shot
well Corky had Down syndrome and there
was something about hitting the end of
the hallway and turning where he
couldn't pick up his lines he had the
hallway and he had that walk but as soon
as he turned there was something that
there was a disconnect they couldn't do
one shot right
the A.D
he just keeps walking and not messing up
his mind walking
the A.D is on the headset this is
Hollywood and you see my cousin and I
are standing there and she walks by us
and we can hear her on the heads that go
Jesus what is wrong with him today I'm
like
today
so I want to tell you you got excited by
a sandwich earlier yeah do you know what
I mean give this dude a break man yeah
we're gonna want dude almost two pages
of dialogue they wanted him to do
one can you do it no dude that's the
difficult for a list that's a lot for me
that's a difficult dude
I got molested the visual no I'm telling
you I was a division one at University
of Colorado the the he was like uh I
don't know you'd worked in the athletic
building and he had a twin brother who
also had Down syndrome he was older and
they were gonna let them go or they're
going somewhere else some
but I was like oh yeah he's so nice you
would always rub my ass he'd always like
I'd be sitting there he'd always rub me
and I thought he rubbed everyone I was
like oh he
did not rub you guys they're like bring
him up on charges I'm thinking about it
yeah wait Brad the first time you told
the story on the on air no I've told
this before maybe when Bobby was on yeah
he would he would fill our Gatorade up
but we didn't know this oh this while he
got fired we found out he'd come in
before like at five in the morning and
lick all the cups and then fill it up
with Gatorade there was a guy and then
they found him putting our he like get
our laundry they found him putting his
the laundry into his clothes there was
anything you'd always rub my ass I just
I was like all right I worked at a
restaurant with this guy this busboy was
from Mexico he didn't speak or whatever
he was and he had he had been caught up
in space was all cut up the little guy
and uh my friend comes home back comes
there and he goes and then we get there
and it's the morning and Wes who owned
the restaurant is like hiding behind the
thing and she goes
um we have a problem I have a wedding
he's licking the jellies yeah because
all the jellies would be it'd be the
little things you put a little jelly out
there with that you know my friend had
to go over and go hey uh in Spanish like
you can't lick the jelly she didn't fire
himself
yeah in the morning don't lick all the
jellies he was going like this
Colorado they woke up earlier to watch
the camera because something's going on
and he was like dude you're talking
about 100 players on the team taking
those wax clubs going
stack them back and then we'd get in
there and fill it up how did they know
something was up it makes me never want
to eat out ever again in my entire life
it all goes on I'm not sure we've all
dude we've all been the benefit shares
of someone but even when they told us
even when they told us everyone was like
all right like all right B you know I
have AIDS or something I took politics
super hot girl yeah this is really hot
chick it keeps breaking in she gets
naked and she licks the cups guys uh
yeah you're right give her a raise I
mean it's gatorade's fantastic which
part of the cup I mean let's be honest
is it does she want to spit in my mouth
let's be honest you need somebody to pay
her bill
is that it Tim you want anymore I think
we're good dude give a quick
oh bump for the show please do sorry we
were here to talk about your show no no
no very funny talk about it it's a
father-son competition show with me and
Jacob wolf your boy makes it her parents
and uh it is on my YouTube channel and
on Facebook it's a we basically Jacob
and I challenge each other to different
things we did boxing uh we did pole
dancing we did we did slam dunk
hilarious it had slam dunk that's the
premiere tonight okay this one yeah
that's tonight oh it's nice and so it's
the best here's the thing I pitched this
show to a bunch of places and it was
just a bunch of execs telling me what it
can and can't be what it wouldn't or
wouldn't be and all this stuff right and
so
um
and so
yeah it's not up there yet
yeah
and so I was like okay
let's
let's set up a show with you and I and
let's have us compete with things and
the loser has to do with really
embarrassing punishment
and so I would pitch I pitch it out to
some people and they're like nah this
isn't going to work this isn't going to
work and I realized man like with all my
channels almost 2 million on YouTube
over 2 million on Facebook over a
million on tick tock
and that I just figured out yo I'm just
leaning into my brand I gotta stop
listening to these execs telling me what
I that they think other people want I
know what the people who watch me want
100 okay and I know that my channels get
more views than their networks correct
so I I was like I'm gonna sell fund this
I put a bunch of dough into it we shot
10 episodes it's the best thing I've
ever done that's awesome it's the best
thing I've ever I can't wait I love the
first episode it was it's funny it's
fast-paced it's also dope with you and
Jacob that's what's cool but here's why
I call it family tussle because season
two could be your family versus his
family yeah it could be Red Sox fans
versus Yankee fans you know what I mean
it could be Bert and his wife first
Thomas Kanye West Jews exactly
exactly just spitballs but it's the I
don't know it truly is the best thing
I've ever done and I if if uh I would
love it if you guys would go just check
it out it's like I'm so proud please go
check out and then you're in Portland
this weekend
premieres tonight on the on the uh
YouTube yeah Joshua and then you're in
uh helium great Club in Portland yep
almost Thursday through Saturday then
Omaha Funny Bone Omaha yep and then I'm
going to Mexico a little break a little
wedding daddy's gonna be a new jacket
there that is going to be a Bridgeport
uh Connecticut Stress Factory this
weekend I then um I then go to London
I'll be back I go to the Chicago improv
October 27 28 29. Charlotte North
Carolina Comedy Zone November 10 11 12.
I got Addison which has to be up there
the following weekend November 17 18 19.
yo are you spending an extra day in
Naples that looks like a long weekend
it's always a Sunday it's the only time
of year I do that why uh I just like
Naples and I don't know why I don't know
why but the food at Captain Brian's is
pretty much oh yeah it's not as good as
our boys
our boy Eric and Christopher the other
guy down in Naples yeah he's still there
but yeah yeah and uh yeah dude it's
[ __ ] unreal that food at Virginia
Naples and he has a feast with the best
wine and we just I eat he's the best
he's from New York and then we [ __ ]
hang out until three in the morning I
love that dude I'm gonna go down I love
I love him
it's all great yeah they're all great uh
and I am in San Jose this weekend we
just announced a new tour it's Ohi thick
tour and we have new dates on there as
well that's funny oh he's thick tort uh
we start in San Jose this Thursday
Friday Saturday Salt Lake City is next
week Wise Guys October 20th through 22nd
Calgary uh the Thursday show on the 27th
is damn near sold out so we had a show
on Friday that's the Rooftop in Calgary
Canada November heavy Texas we're in San
Antonio LOL November 3rd through the 5th
Houston November 10th through the 12th
you were all over it keep going keep
going come on uh Road dogging
[ __ ] big one Washington DC DC
Improv December 15th through the 17th
just went on sale right that's going to
sell out that's the Ohi thick tour
tickets at thick boy.com or fatkz.com
new merch just dropped as well the
tie-dye Josh we love you go watch the
show Josh Wolf YouTube get you some B my
merch is coming guys it's coming all
right we love you man my man thank you
so much